going to begin with the news and that is
President Biden in Poland this morning
after yesterday's surprise and historic
trip to Ukraine he's in Warsaw right now
as we speak for a meeting with the
Polish president and later today Mr
Biden will make a speech to mark one
year since the Russian invasion of
Ukraine at the very same time Russian
President Vladimir Putin has already
given a defiant speech of his own today
vowing to continue to wage this war
Charlie dagada is in Ukraine for us but
we're going to begin with Nancy Cordes
who is traveling with the president he's
in Warsaw right now Nancy good morning
good morning yes we're essentially
getting dueling speeches from President
Biden and President Putin within hours
of each other today the White House
insists this is not an attempt to go
head-to-head with Mr Putin but President
Biden will make the case here at
warsaw's Royal Castle today that Russia
has not prevailed nearly a year into
this war and that democracies around the
world are strengthening a case he made
across the border in war-torn Ukraine
yesterday
landed in Warsaw late last night the end
of a day and a half long journey that
took him from Joint Base Andrews outside
D.C Before Dawn on Sunday to the Poland
Ukraine border by plane and then on a
10-hour journey by train to Kiev
the risky trip to Ukraine months in the
making was shrouded in secrecy the two
journalists allowed on board were only
informed on Friday and told to look out
for email instructions with the subject
line arrival instructions for the golf
tourney it's almost unheard of for an
American president to visit a war zone
without U.S troops on the ground he
arrived delivering more than just a
morale boost
he pledged another 450 million dollars
worth of military aid including
artillery ammunition Javelin anti-armor
missiles and surveillance radar systems
freedom is priceless
it's worth fighting for as long as it
takes today President Biden sits down
with Poland's president his top Europe
adviser Amanda Sloat says there's a
reason Mr Biden has come to Poland twice
in one year they're obviously the main
hub for the security and humanitarian
assistance that we have going through
Poland to get to Ukraine the last time
President Biden was here in March of
2022 he stunned the World by suggesting
Vladimir Putin should be removed from
power for God's sake this man cannot
remain power it was an unscripted moment
and the White House quickly insisted he
was not advocating for regime change
eleven months later Putin is still in
power
the president's trip to Ukraine and his
speech here in Warsaw are meant to send
a message to Putin that Western resolve
has not weakened despite the cost of
supporting Ukraine in fact President
Biden is discussing with the Polish
president at this hour the prospect of
increasing the number of NATO forces
stationed here in Poland on the border
with Russia this comes as Putin
announces just today that he is pulling
out of a long time nuclear reduction
treaty with the U.S Nate
Nancy Cordis and Warsaw thank you